Think back to your childhood for a moment.
When you used to play hide and seek, where
was your go-to hiding spot, the one place
you knew for sure that no one would ever be
able to find you?
Outdoors it might have been inside a garden
shed or garage, or maybe you had a treehouse
where you could lay low as the seekers searched
hopelessly for you.
Indoors, on the other hand, normally no hiding
place can beat a wardrobe, closet, or cabinet
when it comes to keeping yourself totally
undetected.
But what if there was a cabinet you could
find yourself getting lost in?
Something that looks small from the outside
but that contains an unknowable amount of
interior space within?
We call it SCP-432, although some of the researchers
have given it the rather adequate nickname
of the Cabinet Maze.
And it is why you are here, why we at the
SCP Foundation have gathered you; because
you’ll be our next expedition inside SCP-432.
Now, before you start to argue, we’re not
going to send you in there empty-handed.
You’ll be provided with the standard equipment
for a mission like this.
Make sure you’ve got your handheld flashlight
with you and enough additional batteries.
Your headsets have a microphone that will
relay audio back to us back at control, and
we’ll be watching everything through the
camera units you will each have mounted to
your shoulder.
You should also take two bottles of water
each, and the same in energy bars.
We said only two, don’t try to sneak any
extra, we’ll know!
Finally, you all need eight sticks of these
chalk markers.
They’re luminous; you’re going to be leaving
indicators once inside SCP-432, and that will
help you navigate your way around.
Well, they should help.
Hopefully…
As some of you may have heard, this will not
be our first expedition into SCP-432, and
likely won’t be our last either.
Although it’s highly irregular, given the
‘complications’ encountered on our previous
missions, we’ll be providing you with some
select details relating to a few of these
aforementioned prior investigations.
If you were all paying attention when you
were first briefed about this, then you’ll
already be aware that SCP-432 is a steel storage
cabinet first discovered in an abandoned industrial
complex in the UK.
Of course, if that’s all it was then we
wouldn’t be sending you into it.
The first expedition into SCP-432 didn’t
involve a group anywhere near this size, that
time we just sent one D Class into the cabinet.
Once he had stepped inside, his camera feed
showed us our first recorded look at the interior.
From what we could see, the D Class was standing
in a corridor that had been constructed out
of the same corroded, rusty metal as the outer
cabinet.
Following our instructions given via his headset,
this D Class subject – actually, let’s
call him Max – continued down this corridor,
turning around a corner a few meters from
where he’d entered.
Max saw a further, longer tunnel ahead, although
the poor level of lighting made it impossible
to judge just how far it stretched.
There was an ordinary electric lightbulb illuminating
part of this corridor, but not enough to make
more that a few short meters visible.
By the light of his torch, Max followed this
tunnel over forty meters until it split off
in varying directions; almost like a crossroads
of corroded metal.
After conferring with Control, Max made a
mark on the wall nearby, pointing back the
way he came, towards the exit.
That’s an important tip for all of you to
remember; use the equipment we’ve issued
you with in order to find your way back to
safety…
well, try to at least, even if it doesn’t
work.
Making his way down the left tunnel, it was
at this point that Max’s video feed began
to degrade in quality.
From the safety of the Control room, Foundation
technicians noted staticky lines of interference
shooting across their monitors.
After traversing another eleven meters, Max
arrived at a T-junction in the tunnels and
again opted to follow the left path and marked
the way back with his chalk.
It was after that turn that Max heard…
something.
The sound didn’t make its way back to Control
due to all the distortion and interference.
When they asked him what he had heard, Max
waited a moment, listening out for the sound
until…
there it was again.
As quietly as he could while still remaining
audible, he described the noise.
Somewhere off in the distance, further down
the rust-coated corridor, someone or something
was banging against the metal walls.
There were even traces of a voice, shouting
fearfully into the dark labyrinth.
Turning up the audio gain on Max’s camera,
the Foundation personnel at Control could
hear it too.
Noticeably shaken, the D Class continued down
the corridor in the direction of the banging
and shouting, only for him to freeze as he
heard a new sound: someone screaming.
The other noises had stopped immediately after.
Max was getting more and more agitated, demanding
to be allowed to leave.
But Control urged him to explore further.
Arriving at another T-junction, he instead
went right this time, once more using his
chalk to leave a marker.
This is your gentle reminder that you all
need to make this a habit when you go into
SCP-432.
The right side tunnel of this junction led
to a dead-end and doubling back to try the
left hand one only ended up yielding the same
result.
By this point, it had only been thirty-seven
minutes since Max had first entered SCP-432,
and the Foundation doctor assigned to the
cabinet decided that was enough for expedition
one.
Max was recalled, ordered to return to the
entrance, and began doubling back the way
he’d come.
He stopped at the crossroads, remarking that
he’d heard another noise, and Control had
picked up the same thing.
This time it was the sound of the wind, a
gentle breeze was blowing through the tunnel
from somewhere deeper within the maze.
Max’s camera captured a few dead leaves
drifting through one of the tunnels he hadn’t
yet explored.
He was commanded to collect the leaves for
analysis, much to his disapproval; by this
point, he clearly wanted out.
As Max followed the order and drew nearer
to the uncharted corridor, the deafening sound
of a roar echoed through the tunnel, sounding
like that of a bear or a lion.
In a panic, Max dashed back the way he’d
come, directed by the chalk markings he’d
left on the walls.
Foundation Control demanded that he go back
and investigate the source of the roaring,
but he was beyond the point of listening now,
desperate to get away from the dark tangled
mass of dimly lit metal tunnels.
Screaming as he ran, Max sprinted through
the SCP-432 cabinet, collapsing from the sheer,
overwhelming rush of terror.
Now much like the first, expedition number
two only utilized a single member of D Class
to explore more of SCP-432.
Obviously, there’s only so much ground one
person can cover, which is why we’ve recruited
so many of you for the next excursion.
Don’t worry, we’ve already run the numbers
and calculated just how many of you will make
it back in one piece.
From the moment the subject of this second
outing – who we’ll call Kari – was sent
into SCP-432, her camera feed showed something
particularly striking.
The interior of the Cabinet Maze seemed to
differ from how it began during expedition
one.
It was as if the extradimensional space within
the metal storage cupboard had somehow changed
itself, reconfiguring into a different layout.
Instructed by Control, Kari walked slowly
down a long, straight corridor, which continued
forward for about a hundred meters before
splitting into a two-way T-junction.
Taking the right-hand route and leaving behind
a marker, she proceeded a further fifty meters.
This time around, the tunnels within SCP-432
were illuminated more frequently by lightbulbs,
but not quite enough; Kari still needed her
torch to see a little further into the darkness.
She reached a crossroads, although it lacked
any chalk markings, meaning it was not the
same as the one first encountered by Max.
Control commanded Kari to take the left side
tunnel after leaving her own marker, and she
then followed this new route until hitting
a second crossroads.
However, acting without orders from the Foundation,
Kari took the right side passageway.
Despite admonishment from Control, she was
allowed to continue.
However, we would advise following any and
all instructions put to you for the duration
of time that you are inside SCP-432 later
on.
Ahead of her, Kari’s torchlight showed there
to be a third crossroads, but something caused
her to stop before she got closer.
She reported the noise of a rhythmic banging
that reverberated through the rusted metal
walls of the labyrinth.
Staying perfectly still, trying to keep her
breathing low and quiet, Kari nervously asked
about what SCP-432 really was, and where that
ominous sound was coming from.
Naturally, Foundation Control did not provide
any answers.
As Kari delved further into the labyrinth,
her camera feed showed a number of the lightbulbs
in this corridor had been shattered, leaving
shards of glass on the metal floor.
Additionally, she noted that there was an
unpleasant, stomach-churning odor in the air,
that smelled like something dead.
Kari noticed an object a few meters later,
although her camera feed was beginning to
cut in and out as she knelt down to examine
what it was.
She reported it was a sports sneaker, but
as her camera refocused on the abandoned footwear,
the feed suddenly shifted angles, tilting
down towards the floor…
that was covered in blood.
Kari hadn’t realized what it was at first.
There was a layer of a dried brown substance
on the corridor floor, flaking off in places.
Looking up under the light of her torch, Kari
noticed even more had been over the walls,
although it must have been some time ago given
how the blood had long started to dry out
and crackle.
But that did little to make her feel comfortable
at the sight of a long smear trailing away
up the corridor.
Despite her continued complaints about the
sickening, decaying smell, Control instructed
Kari to collect the shoe and samples of the
dried blood for testing.
She asked to be let out of SCP-432, but the
Foundation personnel denied her request, telling
her to continue further down the corridor,
which she did at a much slower, more reluctant
pace.
It was only when her video and audio feeds
started to suffer heavy interference that
Control told her to return.
By now, Kari was panicking, saying she could
hear footsteps behind one of the walls and
made her way back out at a far quicker speed.
For security reasons, details pertaining to
the Foundation’s third SCP-432 expedition
cannot be shared with you all.
Don’t worry, we can still provide you with
information about the fourth and fifth attempts
before you end up heading into the Cabinet
Maze yourselves.
In a departure from the initial two, the fourth
of our expeditions featured a team of three
personnel; two from D Class – who will be
referred to as Leo and Jade – and one SCP
Foundation Technical Assistant, ‘Kay’.
We aren’t currently planning on sending
any more of our own ranks into SCP-432, so
when you venture in there you’ll only have
each other for company...
plus whatever else is inside the labyrinth.
Some of the standard exploration equipment
was divided up amongst the group, with only
Leo given the luminous chalk markers, as well
as a prybar.
Jade was the only member given a shoulder-mounted
video unit, and for their own safety, Kay
was issued with a firearm.
The primary objective of this exploration
of SCP-432 was to use an oxyacetylene cutting
torch – operated by Kay – to cut through
the corroded metal walls of the corridors
within.
Venturing inside, the team made their way
along a series of turns that Foundation Control
chose at random.
They arrived at a crossroads, immediately
noticing something that hadn’t been present
during the earlier expeditions.
The northmost passageway of the crossroads
had two large steel pipes attached to the
walls, almost like those found in factories
or other industrial settings.
Upon receiving a message from Control to examine
the pipes, Kay remarked that the metalwork
was cold to the touch, seemingly with liquid
passing through them as if these were some
form of plumbing system.
Kay requested to cut the pipes open using
their blowtorch, but Control denied and instructed
the group to follow them instead.
They did so for around three hundred meters,
only to find the pipes continued through a
wall that blocked the team’s path.
Under orders to do so, Kay ignited the oxyacetylene
torch and began attempting to cut through
the metal surface that stood like a dead end
in their way.
It was at that point that Jade reported hearing
something behind them, although a sweep of
her camera showed the corridor was empty.
Or, at the very least, it appeared to be empty.
Having made a few cuts into the metal wall,
Kay then allowed Leo to use his prybar to
try and lever a section of it open to allow
the group a way to climb through.
The moment he did, a loud roar was heard coming
from behind the wall.
The terrifying, animalistic sound caused Jade
to scream, backing away in fear.
Only for something on the other side of the
metal to punch at the blowtorched wall, with
enough force to bend its rusted surface outwards.
The video feed from Jade’s camera unit began
to sporadically cut in and out, along with
the audio.
But what did come through were clear sounds
of a struggle.
Violent roaring and gunfire from Kay’s sidearm,
along with screaming from all three members
of the exploration team.
There was something else inside the Cabinet
Maze, some indigenous lifeform that roamed
the long, dark metal corridors, that was now
attacking the latest three to venture inside.
Only Jade made it back to the entrance of
the labyrinth, by following the chalk markers
the group had been leaving on the walls along
the way.
It’s because of how effective this practice
is that we’ve been encouraging you to make
sure you do the same once inside SCP-432.
By the time this D Class returned, she was
in a clear state of complete and utter distress,
as well as severely injured.
She was covered in blood, not all of it her
own.
Neither Jade’s fellow D Class Leo nor Foundation
Technical Assistant Kay made it back.
The personnel waiting outside the rusty cabinet
had to shut SCP-432 after Jade emerged, in
order to prevent whatever creature was inside
from escaping.
When they re-opened the doors after enough
time had elapsed, the interior corridors of
SCP-432 had reconfigured themselves again,
meaning the other two members of expedition
four were lost.
As for D Class member D-8321, she was terminated
shortly after being debriefed.
What was perhaps most curious about this though,
was that Foundation personnel found a large
tuft of brown animal hair had been caught
in her equipment harness, presumably during
the attack.
The hair smelt notably unpleasant, but analysis
showed that it belonged to a known family
of animal.
However, there were also a number of notable
irregularities within its DNA.
Now, that brings us on to expedition number
five.
In a return to form, only a single member
of D Class – we’ll call him Mike – was
sent into SCP-432 this time; though, naturally
during your exploration there will be a few
more of you making your way through those
corridors.
Possibly the most noticeable difference between
this excursion and all of those that had previously
been conducted was that now no light was being
emitted within the corroded metal tunnels.
All the lightbulbs that had once offered at
least a low level of visibility were now smashed,
with Mike noticing there was a substantial
amount of broken glass littering the floor.
Perhaps the creature in there got bored and
broke them all… or maybe it wanted the advantage
of no one being able to see it.
Guided by the instructions Control were issuing,
Mike followed a short corridor about ten meters
along, before stopping at his first of the
T-junctions that seemed to regularly occur
within the Cabinet Maze.
Making a left as Control told him to, Mike
kept his torch on, pointing ahead of him to
alleviate some of the dark.
Following and marking each turning that Control
instructed that he take, much like all the
previous expeditions, Mike reported hearing
strange noises coming from within the labyrinth.
He described the sound of machinery emanating
from some distant part of the maze, as well
as feeling cold.
All the bulbs were still broken, and not one
that he came into contact with provided any
light.
Taking a break to drink some water and recharge
his energy with a ration bar, Mike had reached
almost two and a half thousand meters into
SCP-432, making it deeper into the Cabinet
Maze than anyone previously had…
well, a member of personnel anyway.
The reason we say that is because Mike soon
discovered signs that someone else might have
been hiding within the labyrinth.
He noticed a few old, crumpled tin cans and
a bent fork that had been used to eat their
contents.
Whoever else was that deep inside SCP-432
would likely not still be alive, especially
with the creature lurking in the corridors;
although if they were, perhaps it was them
who broke all the lights to keep themselves
hidden.
Soon after, Mike overheard the sound of a
man sobbing coming from somewhere close by.
Although Control struggled to hear the same,
they instructed Mike to follow the noise of
crying and locate the person responsible.
Chasing through the dark towards whoever it
was, Mike could hardly see a thing, even with
his torch as a light source.
“Hello?
Can you hear me?
I'm coming!” he called, trying to get the
attention of the weeping man.
Instantly, a Foundation Control technician
in his earpiece told Mike not to raise his
voice, reproaching the D Class and warning
that he could draw attention to himself.
When Mike retorted by asking what else was
down in the corridors of SCP-432, no further
answer was provided.
He paused at the next junction where the tunnels
intersected, hearing a long, drawn-out moaning
sound, possibly a scream.
A human scream.
The crying stopped immediately after.
Mike asked Control if they had picked up the
sound, stating that it seemed to have come
from somewhere nearby.
Once again, Control urged him to continue
further into the labyrinth, although now Mike
was trying to move as slowly, and stealthily,
as he possibly could.
Turning a right corner about twenty meters
further down, Mike’s camera feed showed
that he had reached yet another dead end.
The maze blocked his way forward.
Leaning his ear close to the metal, Mike listened
for any further signs of life, only to recoil
at what he heard beyond the blocked corridor.
Crunching, the noise of bones being broken,
and something… someone being eaten by the
lifeform that resides within SCP-432.
Control urged Mike to get out of there, and
he complied, although not without checking
over his shoulder the whole walk back.
At present, we still don’t have an accurate
description of the creature.
Some theories state that it might be imprisoned
inside SCP-432, others suggest that it guards
the labyrinth within and protects it from
trespassers and interlopers.
As for how other human beings – or their
remains, at least – have been uncovered
within the Cabinet Maze?
Well, a number of homeless people had been
reported missing from the industrial complex
where SCP-432 was first uncovered.
Presumably, some of them used that area for
shelter and some ended up inside the cabinet.
Of course, our current objective is to learn
more about the creature.
This is where you all come in.
So, now that we’ve covered the previous
expeditions into SCP-432.
If there are no further questions, we’d
like you all to walk right this way.
What are you waiting for?
Step inside the cabinet.
Of course, we’ll let you back out afterwards…
Now go and check out “SCP-3333 TOWER”
and “SCP-5140 FROZEN BODIES ON EVEREST ARE
ALIVE” for more anomalous areas you really
shouldn’t try to explore yourself.
Don’t believe us?
Maybe you’ll think twice about taking a
trip after you hear what’s waiting for you!